Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Si je vous parle de musique électronique,
à quoi vous allez penser ?
Pour la génération de mes parents, c’était
les grands concerts de Jean-Michel Jarre,
c’était les nappes de synthétiseurs
de Vangelis.
Par musique électronique,
on désigne aussi assez souvent l’électro
en tant que genre musical
et tous les dérivés :
la techno, dubstep, house,
psytrance, dark core,
je ne sais pas si ça vous parle.
Il y a plein plein de choses.
Vous pensez peut-être à la playlist
de votre dernière soirée ?
Boum boum dans les oreilles,
Berlin, les rave parties.
Ou alors complètement autre chose :
l’avant-garde contemporaine un peu bizarre
qui a vous fait peur l’autre jour
sur France Culture.
En tout cas, c’est hyper large
et au final,
on ne sait plus trop de quoi on parle.
Il faut que je vous le précise,
je vais vous parler de musique
électronique, plutôt du son électronique,
de l’idée générale du son électronique.
Avant d’aller plus loin, je dois très
rapidement vous parler du son tout court
pour que ce soit plus clair.
Vous en avez sûrement tous conscience :
le son naît d’une vibration acoustique.
C’est une onde de pression qui
se propage dans l’air jusqu’à nos tympans.
C’est très simple dans l’idée,
c’est-à-dire que tout ce qui vibre -
Notre oreille est sensible à
des fréquences entre 20 et 20 000 Hz,
donc tout ce qui peut vibrer entre
20 fois et 20000 fois par seconde -
je n’irai pas assez vite -
peut être audible.
Dans ma poche, j’ai
une embouchure de trompette.
(Son de la trompette)
Vous avez l’idée.
J’ai l’air clairement débile
sans la trompette qui va avec,
mais avec cette embouchure,
mes lèvres, et un talent non dissimulé,
je génère l’onde de pression.
Le reste de l’instrument va permettre
de contraindre, d’amplifier,
de mettre en forme
cette excitation acoustique.
Tous les instruments de musique
fonctionnent de la même manière :
on a toujours un excitateur
et un résonateur.
Un exemple qui est très parlant,
c’est une corde qui va vibrer
et qui va faire résonner
une table d’harmonie en bois.
Et puis, pourquoi pas -
je dis ça complètement au hasard -
un électroaimant qui fasse vibrer
une membrane en carton.
Vous voyez peut-être là où je veux
en venir, c’est le haut-parleur.
Le haut-parleur, l’arme ultime,
le portail vers un univers parallèle,
incroyablement flexible et malléable,
c’est l’univers du signal électrique
et donc de l’électronique.
Avec un haut-parleur au bout de la chaîne,
on peut tout faire.
On peut déjà, bien sûr, amplifier.
On peut reproduire un enregistrement.
On peut aussi - et c’est ça qui va
m’intéresser aujourd’hui -
générer de l’audio sans avoir même
besoin d’une source acoustique au départ.
Ça, je vais vous le montrer.
C'est un synthétiseur modulaire.
Ça revient à la mode -
enfin, toutes proportions gardées -
mais ça a l’avantage d’être extrêmement
clair et limpide dans l’approche.
On voit vraiment bien ce qu'on fait.
On va faire l’exercice.
On va créer un son électronique ensemble.
Je vais commencer
avec une onde sinusoïdale.
(Son d’une onde sinusoïdale)
Ça, c’est le son électronique
le plus simple qu’on puisse imaginer,
c’est la base, il y a juste une fréquence.
On peut...
(Variation de l’onde sinusoïdale)
en faire varier la fréquence.
Tout l’intérêt du truc, c’est que je vais
pouvoir utiliser des signaux électroniques
pour modifier les paramètres.
Par exemple, ma fréquence,
je la fais varier avec un potentiomètre.
Je peux mettre un générateur
de tension aléatoire,
vous allez voir ce que ça fait.
(Divers bruits électroniques)
Là, j’ai une génération
aléatoire du signal.
Si je veux être un peu plus subtil
et musicien, je peux utiliser un clavier.
C’est quand même très pratique.
Pareil, je vais brancher
mon signal électrique.
Et là, miracle !
(Son d’un orgue électronique)
Voilà, c’est super,
mais il manque quand même un truc.
J’arrive...
Mon son ne s’arrête jamais,
il manque quand même un truc.
Ce que je peux faire,
c’est créer une enveloppe.
On y va.
Vivent les ordinateurs !
Là, maintenant, ça y est,
j’ai une enveloppe - hourra !
(Son d’un orgue électronique)
Pour l’instant, je ne vais pas
vous faire danser avec ça.
Il faut vraiment tout paramétrer,
tout programmer.
L’idée, c’est vraiment : j’ai du signal
électrique, je vais moduler les fonctions.
On n’a pas tout à fait la même approche
qu’un instrument de musique normal.
C’est un synthétiseur,
et je pense qu’on peut le dire,
quelque part, c’est une machine.
J’aimerais vous parler
d’une autre approche,
plus ancienne.
C'est celle qui a préfiguré
la musique électronique telle
qu’on la connaît... en 1920.
En 1920, il faut se rendre compte
que l’électricité, c’est tout neuf.
On sort de la Première Guerre mondiale.
On commence tout juste
à manipuler du signal électrique
avec des composants électroniques,
donc des tubes, des lampes triodes.
C'est le début de la radio
à grande échelle.
En Russie, un jeune et brillant ingénieur,
Lev Sergueïevitch Termen,
qu’on francise Léon Thérémine,
invente ce drôle d’appareil
qui porte son nom.
J’ai l’impression d’être au Salon
de l’auto et de révéler la nouvelle Tesla,
mais ce n’est pas ça.
Le thérémine.
Là, vous le voyez,
il n’y a pas de clavier.
Heureusement, il n’y a pas de câble.
Il y a des boutons, mais ce n’est pas
avec ça qu’on va jouer.
C’est vraiment juste
pour quelques réglages.
Là, la démarche, c’est deux antennes.
A gauche, on a le volume.
(Son plus ou moins fort)
Et à droite, on a la hauteur du son.
(Son allant vers l’aigu)
Bon. Et c’est tout, il n’y a rien de plus,
Je vais vous montrer un truc.
(Notes de la gamme)
Comment on joue du thérémine.
On a vraiment juste la hauteur,
le volume, et rien de plus.
J’ai fait des études scientifiques
et beaucoup de musique à côté.
Ce fut un vrai coup de foudre
quand j’ai découvert ça.
Je jouais de la musique classique,
du violoncelle.
Donc naturellement,
quand j’ai commencé le thérémine,
c’était avec la musique classique.
Je vais vous jouer quelque chose -
il est temps, peut-être.
(Musique classique au thérémine)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
C’est uste un petit extrait.
Vous avez peut-être vu, il y a quand
même une dimension un peu vocale.
On pourrait penser à quelqu'un qui chante.
Et pourtant, ce qui est fou, c’est que le
son en lui-même reste vraiment simple.
(Son aigu)
Il se passe émotionnellement
autant de choses
que ma pauvre sinusoïde de tout à l’heure.
Donc tout le travail,
ça va être de donner vie à ce timbre
électronique simpliste,
et on peut le faire.
Ça demande autant d’investissement
qu’apprendre le violon
ou la flûte traversière.
Il faut développer une technique de jeu
et c’est dans l’articulation
que tout va se jouer.
(Sons de thérémine)
Vous voyez l’idée :
pour passer d’une note à l’autre,
il y a 36 000 manières à chaque fois,
c’est vraiment hyper expressif.
Voilà le thérémine.
Il y en a eu d’autres, des instruments
de musique électronique expressifs,
entre autres, les ondes Martenot.
C’est un instrument français,
il faut le souligner.
C’est un peu la même idée.
On a un ruban qui permet
de passer entre les notes,
on a une touche d’intensité derrière un
tiroir qui permet de générer une attaque -
comme l’antenne gauche du thérémine -
et un clavier, oui, c’est vrai, mais
attention, pas n’importe quel clavier :
il est suspendu.
Eh oui !
Du coup, on peut en faire
un vibrato personnel.
Ça existe encore, les ondes Martenot.
Ça, un peu moins, mais quand même aussi.
C’est enseigné au Conservatoire de
Paris, de Strasbourg, de Montréal.
Mais ça reste quand même marginal.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
entendu des ondes Martenot.
Quelles perspectives
pour l’approche expressive ?
Je vais vous montrer autre chose.
Ça,
c’est un  instrument moderne.
Ça s’appelle le continuum.
Ça ressemble de très loin,
en fermant les yeux et sans
lumière, à un clavier de piano,
mais en fait, c’est un tapis en néoprène
avec des ressorts dessous,
et...
(Son électronique)
On contrôle le son par pression, et ce qui
est dingue c’est que, du coup, c’est...
expressif - pour changer de mot.
(Son du continuum)
(Applaudissements)
J’aurais peut-être dû
me préparer un petit peu.
Vous voyez la démarche.
Ce qui est incroyable -
Objectivement, j’ai un son
qui est complexe.
Il est programmé pour avoir une attaque
et en même temps, je peux le soutenir.
Voilà.
On a vraiment l’interface pour
le contrôler dans toutes ses dimensions.
Et ça, ça se ressent
parce que, si je reprends encore une fois
ma sinusoïde pénible du début,
(Bruit sinusoïdal)
Là, déjà, je peux quand même
impliquer quelque chose.
L’instrument existe avant même le timbre.
(Son du continuum)
Comme le thérémine, on peut
vraiment impliquer quelque chose.
J’aimerais dire un truc important :
c’est qu’en musique,
les innovations ne remplacent
jamais celles d’avant.
Par exemple, la guitare électrique n'a
jamais remplacé la guitare classique.
Le piano n’a pas enterré le clavecin.
Enfin, un peu quand même,
mais ça existe encore.
Et pareil, l’ordinateur n’a pas vraiment
remplacé le synthétiseur analogique,
même s’il en serait largement capable -
[il est capable] de faire beaucoup plus.
Toutes les démarches peuvent coexister.
Moi, j'aime bien d'ailleurs
jongler avec tout ça.
J’ai encore des progrès à faire,
mais ça me plaît d’hybrider les approches.
En tout cas, je remarque une chose,
plus sérieusement,
c’est que la démarche de créer
des interfaces de contrôle
reste sous-développée
par rapport à toute la recherche
faite sur des nouveaux timbres,
des nouveaux sons.
On a une technologie
monstrueuse aujourd’hui.
Ça, c’est un concept des années 60,
le synthétiseur modulaire.
Aujourd'hui, on parle même beaucoup
de l'intelligence artificielle.
Tout ce que ça peut débloquer en termes
de création sonore, c’est incroyable.
On en est toujours là à utiliser
des claviers pour contrôler nos sons,
mais il y a peut-être
besoin d’autre chose.
Ce que j’aurais envie de dire,
c’est qu’il ne faut pas avoir peur
des idées oubliées du passé,
il ne faut pas avoir peur des ovnis.
Je suis du coup très curieux de
voir ce qui peut arriver à l’avenir.
En tout cas, ne perdons jamais ce lien
sensible qu’on a avec le son
et qui fait de la musique un langage,
un moyen d’expression
extrêmement riche et profondément humain.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)